so
we mentioned camus oh yeah i love him
is there um this is this is this is a
question that people
like love when i ask of really smart
people
no uh what uh what books let's say
three books if you can uh think of them
technical fiction philosophical would
you
uh had a big impact on you or would you
recommend to others sure
uh the machiavellians by james burnham
uh this is a book about how politics
works in reality as opposed to how
people
imagine it working um mentis moldbug
who's a figure in these circles who's
respected by a lot of people
i was giving a talk and there was a
bunch of panelists
and we were asked what book would you
recommend i said the machiavellians
independently of me that was the book he
had recommended it's out of print it's
hard to find but that would be
one is that his book or no james burnham
came back 1941 i think
so uh can can you pause on the mulches
what's that it's just moldbug
that's the code name right like that guy
name that guy's dependent curtis jarvin
it's his real name he's in he swims in
your circles
he doesn't kind of progress oh he's
originally programmed yeah
he comes up as a person that i should
talk with or i should know about but
then i read a few of his things and they
seem quite dangerous
they're very long and verbose but i
think he's an amazing thinker
yeah but he's the one who had the idea
of sending the tanks to harvard yard
but doesn't he have like uh
he has some radical view i forget what
they are very radical views yeah he
wants a military
coup but you're saying he's a serious
thinker this
is worthy uh of not worthy
i don't know that you would enjoy having
a conversation with him i think a lot of
people enjoy seeing it happen but i
think it'd be a lot of talking past each
other and
and it would be interesting what do you
uh
okay um what do you agree what do you
disagree i agree with him
that politics has to be looked at
objectively
and without kind of an emotional um
connection to different schools
i talk about him a lot in my book on the
new right um
disagree i don't think a military coup
is a good idea
uh he's he doesn't think anarchism is
stable i disagree
um i mean me and him i did his live
stream with him we just dorked out a lot
about history and like you know people
who've
fallen in the memory hall so i mean he's
got a lot of writing
so so you know the sense i got from him
was that if i talk with him a lot of
people would be upset with me
for giving him a platform yeah i think
he's on that edge where they want to
read him out of
what is acceptable discourse what's his
most controversial
i mean you keep mentioning the tanks is
that the most controversial viewpoint
does he have a race thing no he's the
the alt-right doesn't particularly like
him in many ways because he's not a big
on the race thing i don't know what
would be his most controversial view
uh uh to be honest i think because he
is radical in terms of his analysis of
culture anytime someone's a radical that
is dangerous because it's dangerous
okay book uh so that's one
no if and if you read atlas shrug before
being the fountainhead you're doing
yourself an enormous disservice don't
you dare do it
on the philosophical because everything
novel every every level
fountain has a better novel fountain
head superfluous if you read out the
shrugged first
fountain heads about psychology and
ethics
uh it does not have to do with her
politics other than its implications
so it's by far the superior book um the
third one
oh this is a good one question let me
see what there's so many good books out
there that i love
i i'm going to this is not really my
third choice but i'll throw it out there
because i
um this is such an important world view
especially people on the right are you
virtue signaling
no this is counter signaling um thaddeus
russell's book a renegade history of the
united states
his thesis is that it's the degenerates
that give us all freedom and
things like prostitutes things like
madams things like slaves things like
immigrants because they were so low
status
they could get away with things that
then people who are higher status
demanded and so on and so forth so i
think that thesis
and it really has extreme um
consequences
in uh uh thinking
and no john jonathan height the
righteous mind that's those are the four
is that his best i haven't read any of
his stuff the only one you want
okay that was four but of course
forget that we'll put tight in there you
would
no forget that yes those are the three
you